France on Ta surtout connu pour ton rôle
de professeur de danse dans la 10è
saison de la Star Académie mais c'est un
danseur international c'est un monstre
en danse tu arriv avec lui sur un dance
floor frère tout le monde se plusous
Yanis qui arrive c'est fini hein je vous
le dis alors j'ai adoré moi l'année
dernière tu étais ma star
tu mais tu étais maar là-bas donc quoi
cette année on va pas te voir non on va
pas me voir cette année non mais attends
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce délire
là non mais mon Yanis c'est pas possible
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là
euh qu'est-ce qui s'est passé t as dit
dans une interview que la saison avait
été particulièrement éprouvante oui j'ai
fait euh tu ce que je te propose vas-y
on va faire un truc la fausse interview
donc là tu vas redire que c'était
éprouvant tout ça et après on fera la
vraie ou tu nous diras les vraies
raisons donc alors donc c éprouvant pour
toi c'était très éprouvant
euh c'est non j'ai fait comme un petit
burnout en fait aussi pendant ouais
pendant l'émion tu partais à 7h de chez
toi et tu rentrais pas avant minuit
ouais au plusutôt et donc euh tu as même
fait une pelade j'ai fait une pelade
ouais j'avais perdu j'avais un petit
trou dans la tête donc tout le monde
disait dans les commentaires mais
qu'est-ce qu'il a se touché les cheveux
tout le temps c'est parce que j'arrêtais
pas de mettre ce côtél là là elle est
partie la pelade elle est partie bon
très bien euh non tu as fait beaucoup de
crise d'angoisse pendant le tournage de
l'émission aussi ouais j'ai fait j'ai
commencé à partir du prime 3 enfin non
la vérité c'est que j'ai toujours fait
des crises angoisse c'est pas nouveau
mais c'est
revenu très agressivement à partir du
prime 3 ouais il que tu te réveillais
pendant la nuit en pensant que tu étais
filmé ça m'est arrivé une fois la
première semaine mais en fait il faut ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que c'est
très bizarre une émission comme la
starac on est à la télé tous les jours
on a la quotidienne on n pas juste le
prime time tous les samedis on a la
quotidienne tous les jours plus le prime
donc toute la semaine tu es à la
télé ça doit être très dur d'être à la
télé non non mais mais mais attends mais
attends mais nous on est toute la
journée je veux dire au château aussi
c'est filmé je veux dire on est filmé
non stop à partir du moment on rentre
dans C machine donc la première semaine
où j'ai dû un peu m'adapter comme ça
c'est vrai que la nuit j'avais un peu ça
m'est arrivé une fois c'est vrai de me
réveiller en plein milieu de la nuit et
de penser queil y avait une caméra quoi
tu fais très bien le mec qui se réveille
tu vois ah non vraiment c'est vrai là je
me suis dit il y a un problème quand
même non et ouais tu pensais qu'il y
avait une caméra bah écoute j'espère
qu'elle était pas tout le temps là même
quand tu faisais autre chose que dormir
euh pas le temps de faire autre chose tu
vois pour évacuer ce stress tu faisais
quoi alors
euh
non une fois c'est pas pour évacuer
stress je faisais quoi c'est une fois je
suis j'avais j'avais pas de non non non
ça a commencé avec cette première fois
attends laisse-moi parler Cyril ri je
j'avais donc pour la première fois pas
de répétition un samedi avant l' prime
normalement j'ai toujours des répètes et
là tous mes tableaux les répétitions
étaient le vendredi donc je me suis
autorisé je me suis dit bon allez ça
faisait 3 semaines déjà j'en peux plus
je me suis dit je vais me faire un resto
avec mes potes et et et
cette fameuse phrase un seul verre hein
puis après je rentre oui euh et donc
voilà j'ai fait la fête ce soir-là euh
je voulais fêter l'événement je voulais
fêter l'expérience tout ça j'étais
heureux en vrai c'est parti d'un bon
d'un bon sentiment rappelle queab
d'alcool est dangereux pour la santé tu
étais beurré c'est ça et et donc bon ben
je suis allée trop loin comme je sais
bien faire euh et ouais ouais et donc
c'est vrai que je suis arrivée le
lendemain avec une vraie gueule de bois
quoi vraiment et donc prime où j'ai où
j'ai donc ces
lunettes bah oui c'est ça les mettre on
pe les mettre s' vous plaîtou merci
c'est rien c'est une petite photo à
mettre merci ouais donc là tu étais beré
làta non j'étais pas Bré mais j'étais en
vrai lendemain de soirée vraiment et au
final mais ça ne m'a pas c'est ça que je
soulligne quand même c'est que ça a été
finalement le prime que moi enfin dont
je me souviens le plus au final parce
que c'est celui où j'ai le plus kiffé
c'est cel où j'étais super spontané
j'étais vivant je suis monté sur la
table j'ai j'ai j'ai du coup j'ai eu
aussi a pardon mon langage mais j'ai eu
les couilles de porter cette tenue et
d'assumer les lunettes et tout et je
pense qu'il y avait un truc je c génal
beaucoup couill hein je te cache pas
c'est pour ça qu'on t'aime aussi hein
non mais c'est vrai il paraît que tu as
mal vécu ton passage au energy Music
Awards oui alors c'est vraiment là que
tous
ces le déclencheur en vrai c'est ça
c'està-dire que ça été il y a eu un
avant et un après quoi sûr oui qu en
vrai non en vrai c'est ça qu'il faut
vraiment souligner c'est que c'est
vraiment c'est même pas en fait pendant
la Stara que l'expérience euh enfin que
quelque chose a vraiment tourné c'est
vraiment cette soirée là au energy Music
Award où j'ai très très mal vécu alors
là il faut savoir juste pour remettre
dans le contexte je suis donc la la 6e
semaine de l'aster academmy donc
l'avant-dernière semaine j'en peux
plus et on m'apprend vraiment en
dernière minute que je suis invité pour
les NMA pour aller donner en plus le
prix de l'artiste francophone de l'année
donc moi qui pensais que c un petit prix
tranquille vers la fin plus de pression
on m'envoie donc la liste il y a
vraiment pas mal de nommés et tout donc
c'est long j'essaie de faire un petit
texte tout ça en fait ben c'est de la
pression c'est de la pression c'est un
exercice que je connais pas parce que là
on demande pas d'être prof de danse on
me demande pas et c'est c'est un
exercice que je connaissais pas j'ai
voulu bien le faire j'arrive à Canne
c'est la folie de canne et pendant les
anéas je sais pas si quelqu'un voilà
enfin c'est vraiment un délire je suis
canois mais là c'est un délire aussi on
nous attend à l'aéroport on nous attend
devant l'hôtel on crie donc je sais pas
ça commence à Tourbillon ouais
tourbillon je suis pas bien je mange pas
de la journée faut le souligner ah ouais
pas a un banage et et donc bref je fais
mon
passage et je sors du passage et je je
je je lâche vraiment j'en peux plus et
je bois donc je je demande une bouteille
de champagne ouais bien sûr j'aime le
champagne j'assume mais tu as
raison dem une boutille de champagne en
arrivant au loge et à savoir que j'étais
pas le seul à boir du champagne ce soirl
he
non et donc au final bon je la bois un
peu vite avec le stress et le fait de
pas avoir mangé de la journée et tout ce
qui toute l'expérience en général là tu
as eu un je me mets en fait vraiment à
avoir une de mes plus grosses crises
angoisses de ma vie c'est-à-dire que
c'est ingérable sur le moment je me
reconnais même pas moi-même je peux pas
le contrôler je pleure je tremble je
n'arrive plus à respirer je pense que je
vais mourir je pense j'ai envie de
mourir enfin c'est c'est c'est vraiment
intense c'est une vraie c'est pas je
pleure je suis triste et je suis
vraiment dans un état et et qui n'est
pas en fait gérable et on peut pas se
contrôler dans ce moment-là et donc je
je demande à me faire à me faire évacuer
de du palais des festival mais par
derrière parce que il y a tellement
c'est tellement voilà enfin c'est canal
donc on me sort par la plage et je
rentre à mon hôtel tranquillement sauf
que en fait pour parce que c'est
vraiment ça donc la grosse histoire donc
désolé c'est un petit peu long mais ça
la soirée qui a tout changé Mo j'adore
et en fait arriv il revient le mec des
meurtrre après là d'hier non non non
t'inquiète pas non non mich c'est quoi
c'est qui non non t'inquiète pas j'ai
pas compris la blague non rien à voir
avec toi c'est un mec Michel Marie n'
pas il sera pas là ce soir c'était son
heure c'est pour ça il sera pas là il
sera pas là ce soir Michel
Marie alors et donc j'adore moi Yanis
alors c'est quoi et donc je rentre à
l'hôtel et donc j'ai cette personne là
qui était parce que je suis pas alléo m'
accompagner et c'est je pense c'est la
grave c'est l'erreur que j'ai fait c'est
ça je pense que j'aurais dû y aller
accompagné d'un ami et ne pas être seul
et ne pas me retrouver seul là-bas euh
et j'ai pas fait ça parce que bon ben
voilà bref manque de budget aussi comme
d'Able et euh h et donc une enfin que je
pensais mais ça c'est ma très grande
erreur dans toute l'aventure une
personne qui travaille donc dans la
production de TF1 donc pas enmol et pas
dmls parce qu'il y a trois groupes comme
tu le sais donc dmls enmol TF1 tu peux
dire du mal de TF1 pas de dmls ni de en
démo mais je on en parlera après de ça
on en parlera après de ça que je mais
c'est pas le but mais on par après mais
et donc voilà et il se trouve que donc
cette personne est au courant que qui s
s'est passé ça et que je rentre dans cet
état là ouais donc m'envoie un message
en fait moi je pense que je me calme et
ça repart au premier message ça repart
et donc elle me demande si je veux
qu'elle passe et je lui dis ben je t'en
supplie pass oui passe parce que je vais
vraiment et j'allais vraiment pas bien
elle
pass
ouais elle passe elle vient et donc là
bon ben bah il y a tout qui tombe quoi
on est 6e semaine je raconte toute ma
vie Racon m les couilles non les
couilles restent en place Cyr tu es
gentil euh non mais je veux dire j'ai
vraiment tous les vieux démons je parle
de tout je parle pas juste là des starac
je parle vraiment de tout j'ai un vrai
lâchage vraiment je je je je me lâche
complètement euh la meuf connais toute
ma vie à ce moment-là tu vois et c'est
vrai que je peux comprendre que ça fait
assez peur sur le moment que je dois
faire peur parce que je faisais
certainement peur parce que j'étais
vraiment pas contrôlable et moi-même je
me faisais peur surtout çaou tu vois le
genre sauf que donc moi qui pense quand
même que parce que ça fait quand même 6
semaines qu'on travaille ensemble
qu'elle vient toujours dans ma loge
qu'elle est on est copains copines je me
dis non mais en fait tu sais c'est un
cocon la ST academmie donc tuas pas le
temps de voir tes vrais amis elle a tout
été bavé ouais voilà et en fait au final
donc il s'avè que le lendemain je
comprends direct que tout le monde est
au courant de ce qui s'est passé et en
fait pourquoi parce que tout simplement
tout le monde me dit en gros qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose au anemma mais moi
enema je sais exactement ce que j'ai
fait j'ai fait l'émission et j'étais
dans ma chambre j'ai pas fait d'ATER
party j'ai pas fait de soirée j'ai pas
pu parti pourant c'était prévu mais j'ai
même pas pu donc je sais donc pour moi
quand on me dit c'est wema qui s'est
passe quelque chose je sais de quoi on
parle je sais de qui on parle direct tu
sais que c'est la meuf qui est venue
voir de la production TF1 prod ex voilà
et donc et sauf que là en fait c'est là
qu'on m'a expliqué que du coup le
nouveau problème c'est que là c'était
TF1 qui était au courant donc en gros
entre guillemets si tu veux on pouvait
plus mais ils étaient au courant de quoi
que tu pouvais avoir un burnout qui
était au courant que
j'étais à ce moment-là en tout cas pas
stable à ce moment-là c'est vrai que
j'ai
ta que j'étais en burnout mais mais non
mais je veux dire je lui ai confié des
choses donc va savoir moi je ne sais pas
ce qu'elle a si elle a raconter juste
que j'étais pas bien sur là juste que
j'étais en crise angoisse ou est-ce
qu'elle aller raconter ma vie mes
traumas mon passé je ne sais pas parce
que j'ai tout dit je ne sais pas ce
qu'elle allé raconter mais en tout cas
elle a clairement assez raconté pour
faire peur elle t' fait du T un peu plus
que du T Mme oui elle t'a ta vie
non non mais ça va pas ou quoi m'a pas
du tout ma vie j'avais une vie
avant la starag j'ai
alors et donc et donc après ça on t'a
fait comprendre que il valit mieux que
tu te
reposes non non ça s'est pas passé comme
ça après ça euh non non après ça il y
avait même enfin moi j'étais on a on
avait moi je suis pas comme elle je
répèterai rien
personne
canne après après ça non au contraire
justement il y avait des des enfin je
veux dire quand on parlait au début vers
la fin de la starac euh on m'a mentionné
pour la saison 2 on parlait déjà un
petit peu de la saison 2 enfin c'est tu
l' pas fait pourquoi tu l' fait pas al
alors justement euh je l'ai pas fait au
final mais c'est ça c'était ça la grande
surprise c'est que moi je pensais en
fait si tu veux après la starx j'ai dit
ok là j'ai compris que j'ai pété un
câble j'ai compris que j'ai besoin de
repos que j'ai compris que j'ai besoin
aussi de de que j'ai été surexosé que
j'ai besoin
de dist de quitter ce monde là un peu et
de mettre de la distance et de me
retrouver et en fait donc moi j'ai dit
ok je j'entends je prends ma
responsabilité j'ai merdé j'ai fait des
choses
voilà qui sont pas forcément pro il y a
pas de souci je vais m'occuper de moi je
vais prendre tout ce temps pour pour me
pour me prendre en main pour aller voir
un PSI pour m'occuper de moi quoi pour
de mon bien-être et en fait il faut
savoir qu'à ce moment-là on est en
décembre quoi donc la starx c'est en
novembre là donc en fait moi je me dis
voilà j'ai le temps c'est pas comme si
je te dis en 10 jours je change ma vie
et que tu crois pas j'ai le temps ok ok
pas de souci pas de souci bon bah il
s'avè qu'au final en février on m'a mis
un stop en disant est-ce que tu es allé
en en en cure j'ai C de la meuf qui a
tout répété qui a dû dire qu' était tu
tu tu buvais mais je buvais parce que je
buvais du champagne tu suis pas cyil si
mais donc elle a dit que tu buvais donc
ils on ils ont dit ouais il il boit trop
il fera pas la starque c'est c'est alors
tu veux que je te dis je sais pas ce
qu'elle a dit je dis la vérité je sais
pas on va on se dit tout tous les deux
t'exquez moi je sais je sais la vérité
je sais la vérité je sais tu peux la
connaître mieux que moi mais vas-y je
sais la vérité qu'on m'a dit mais moi je
suis là et je te dis la vérité je
t'explique j'ai des ramifications
partout moi je te le dis moi
moi dis la vérité c'est quoi vas-y ce
qu'on m'a dit c'est on voulait reprendre
Yanis mais Yanis a des problèmes
d'alcool et on ne peut pas le reprendre
sur la starac Gill Verdez est-ce que tu
as les mêmes infos que moi j'ai les
mêmes infos et si vous me permettez je
voudrais aussi poser exactement les
mêmes infos poser une petite question à
Yanis parce que Yanis j'espère que ça va
vous permettre de lever un petit doute
sur une rumeur insidieuse qui court les
rédactions et comme vous êtes franc vous
allez répondre ce qu'on dit ce que
certains prétendent en tout cas c'est
qu'il y aurait pas que l'alcool c'est
que est-ce que vous auriez pris à cette
soirée là ou d'autres produits par
exemple des produits stupéfiants qui
auraient pu faire non mais je préfère
vous le dire vous savez que ça tourne je
sais que ça tourne c'est pour ça que
AC avez-vous pris des produits
stupéfiants et est-ce que ça aurait pu
revenir aux oreilles de TF1 qui donc
aurait dit on arrête tout avec Yanis
d'accord alors non c'était excusez la
sincérité de la question mais je préfère
vous la poser
Perm de répondette question cétait juste
si vous avez vraiment c doigts parce que
les gens qui ont des gants toute la
journée en général ils ont que qure
doigts 10 tu vois j'en ai 10 bien sûr
c'est pas Mick j' 10 mais là en plus la
question est intéressante j'en ai 10
donc ok belle
[Rires]
intervention et donc du coup pour
répondre pour répondre à ta question
c'est exactement pour ça que j'ai fait
le parisin pour mettre la chose au clair
j'ai bu oui j'ai buvaé mais après
attention j'explique oui je buvais du
champagne dans ma loge avant attention
on parle que du samedi soir déjà pour
commencer la semaine je ne bois pas je
suis au château on l'a vu sinon enfin ça
serait vu à la télé j'ai très bien fait
mon boulot les seuls moments où je je
c'est vrai que je m'autorisé et c'est
aussi pour me mettre dans le mood parce
que c'est 4h de prime bordel un samedi
soir et qu'il faut être festif faut pas
se faire en voilà quoi tu vois je suis
comme ça je buvais effectivement avant
les primes dans ma loge j'avais du
champagne et je buvais pendant les
primes dans mon mug j'avais du champagne
et je buvais après les primes c'est vrai
je l'ai dit je l'ai reconnu voilà et
malheureusement ce qui se passait c'est
que du coup je devenais fragile et le
mix de tout ça plus la fatigue plus la
pression faisait que M angoisses mes
crises angoisses venaient et devenait de
plus en plus régulière et seulement le
problème c'est que si à la rigueur
j'avais juste fait ça mais j'avais fermé
ma gueule et j'avais dit à personne ça
serait passé crème parce qu'on aurait
juste dit ben en fait il est festif il
boit un peu de champagne mais il fait le
taf parce que c'est ça qui s'est passé
en revanche non en revanche par contre
c'est que j'ai ouvert ma bouche moi-même
en appelant les mauvaises personnes pour
leur dire moi-même que j'étais mal et
que j'avais besoin en gros d'aide mais
ça c'est ça ma grosse erreur et c'est
pour ça que je dis que c'est de
l'hypocrisie au final parce que si
j'avais rien dit je serais encore sur la
deuxème saison c'est tout simplement de
l'hypocris voilà après juste je veux
juste comme ça je suis lancé ça va tu
parles continuer je vérifie le nombre de
doigts c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse
sont bien 10 j'ais dire un truc vulgaire
non tu en as déjà av comme ça des choses
oui bon j'ai rien dire encor et non je
veux juste finir sur ça comme ça après
tu peux me poser les questions que tu
veux mais je veux bien mettre quelque
chose au clair je ne suis pas venu là ce
soir où j'ai pas fait l'interview pour
être pour déclarer il y a une mouche qui
me volle pour déclarer la guerre avec
TF1 ou avec qui que ce soit je ne veux
pas la guerre en revanche je veux la
paix avec moi-même c'est ça la
différence et la nuance je voulais
expliquer ma vérité parce que un ça m'a
fait beaucoup de bien de le dire parce
que je suis quelqu'un d'entier parce que
j'en ai pas honte de cette vérité je
n'ai pas honte de moi je suis fière de
ce que j'ai fait je suis fière de mon
parcours et parce que aussi je n'ai plus
de place pour des bagages supplémentaire
dans ma vie c'est juste ça aussi j'ai
non j'ai assez porté de choses j'ai un
passé compliqué comme pas mal d'artistes
je suis écorché vif j'ai j'ai les choses
j'ai porté beaucoup de choses toute ma
vie et j'ai plus la place j'ai plus tu
me Gaves un petit peu mais je l si tu
veux bien je veux bien finir mon
interview et puis après on peut parler
de toi Tu Long non mais non intéressant
trs
intéressants intérant gentil mais voilà
bref donc je viens pas là pour faire la
guerre avec qui que ce soit je vi faut
le dire entre autres on va faire la
guerre en loge après par non mais je
m'en fous on y mais Yanis donc ce que je
disais ma ma version c'est c'est la même
que ta c'est la même version donc c'est
en fait c'est ce que nous expliquit
Yanis c'est que il a il a fait une
soirée ça a été mal interprété par une
personne avec il avait une confiance à
cette personne elle l'a trahi elle a
fait passer Yanis pour un mec qui avait
des problèmes voilà d'alcool et s'est
remonté aux oreilles de TF1 et TF1 a dit
on arrête avec Yanis parce que ça
surtout additionné ça s'est additionné
au 3è prime et à toutes les fois où j'ai
parce que c'est pas que cette soir je
n'ai jamais dit ça de toute manière
c'est très clair j'ai tout dit je n'ai
rien caché je je tout est dit j'ai fait
une interview j'ai tout dit je n'ai plus
rien voilà d'ailleurs je veux clôturer
ce chapitre de ma vie en venant là ce
soir ça veut dire que je l'ai fait sur
papier en interview je fait maintenant
en face et après bonne émission bonne
chance à tout le monde il y a pas de
problème je je je suis sûr que
l'émission va cartonner la star de
l'émissione l'émission comme
je n manquer je te le dis parce que moi
je moi je t'adore mais c'est très gentil
tu revienes me voir alors quand aussi tu
viens pas nous voir un peu des fois
comme ça tu restes mais je vais revenir
je vais revenir non mais c'est vrai
comme ça tu on fait des petites Coré
tous les deux et tout pas chaud sans
rigoler je suis chaud moi je suis
bouillant moi jeore il sera là lui aussi
[Applaudissements]
j'adore il a c'est un énorme talent je
le dis et ça moi j'adore les
personnalités comme ça j'adore comme y
aussi c'est une personnalité incroyable
plus contre lui il est très sympathique
il est incroyable je te dis c'est un
génie vous êtes deux génies dans dans
vot plus il est très doué ouais je sa je
sais pas ce qu'il a vos doigts mais bon
pas je sais
pase la journée ça me CR non mais
t'inquiète mais je fais pas toute la
journée tu sais ça s'appelle la mode ça
s'appelle la fassion tu vois ça me
rassure beaucoup parce que ça fait
psychopathe les G mais
t'inqui et moi tu reviens voir quand tu
veux parce que je avec plaisir non mais
et merci de me recevoir et merci à
chaque fois d'être bienveillant au fin
toujours et si tu veux venir même avec
nous quelque fois ça sera un plaisir et
ben avec plaisir je kiff que tu viennes
un peu nous voir ave plaisir si tu peux
relooker de trois personnes ici c'est
catastrophique merci on va se retrouver
dans un instant une manifestation dev M6
pour protester contre la diffusion un
documentaire sur Stéphane Plaza est-ce
que vous trouvez ça normal euh ou pas on
aura les dernières infos d'ailleurs sur
Stéphan Plazza parce que ça a rebondi
aujourd'hui et vous allez voir cette
histoire fou folle 12 décès suspects de
patients opérés pour de simples
fractures dans un hôpital dévuges le cri
du cœur des familles il rentrait pour
une fracture et il il revenait plus
c'est un truc de fou al on sait pas ce
qui se passe là-bas on aura des
élérément de réponse dans un instant
vous allez voir c'est l'histoire folle
du jour ce sera dans un instant à tout
de suite allez itar